Mein Name ist Ucak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Analysegespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit anverstanden?
Ja.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Frau Kerstin. Analyse Kerstin.
Analyse Kerstin. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen langsam bestabieren?
K-E-R-S-T-I-N. Kerstin.
Ja.
Hoffmann. H-O-F-M-N. Hoffmann.
Okay. Wie darf ich Sie ansprechen? Frau Hoffmann, oder?
Frau. Ja. Frau.
Frau Hoffmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 3. Mai 1987.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 60 Kilogramm.
Okay. Danke für die Information. Frau Hoffmann, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was Überschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ja, Doktor. Heute bin ich mit meinem Mann hierher gekommen, weil ich vor etwa 3 Stunden plötzlich einen Anfall hatte.
Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie früher einige Beschwerden gehabt? Oder ist das das erste Mal?
Ja, das erste Mal.
Okay. Könnten Sie bitte den Anfall genau beschreiben? Also wann ist er passiert? Wie ist er passiert?
Meine Arme und Beine haben stark gezucht. Es waren unkontrollierte Bewegungen im ganzen Körper.
Mein Mann sagt, dass ich vorher etwa eine Minute lang ganz erstarrt war. Und der Anfall danach ungefähr eine Minute gedauert hat, Doktor.
Okay. Frau Hoffmann, wenn ich alles richtig verstanden habe, hatten Sie einen Unfall vor 3 Stunden?
3 Stunden? Ja, oder?
Vor 3 Stunden, Doktor. Nicht...
Vor 3 Stunden?
Vor 3 Stunden. Aber es war eine Minute oder etwas Minute.
Okay. Sie waren vor dem Anfall eine Minute erstarrt?
Ja, ja, ja. Ganz erstarrt war, ja.
Ja, und der Anfall hat eine Minute gedauert, richtig?
Mein Mann sagt, dieser Anfall hat eine Minute gedauert, ja.
Okay. Also Sie haben Ihr Bewusstsein verloren, richtig?
Ja, ja, Doktor. Ich war in den letzten 3 bis 4 Tagen sehr nervös und innerlich unruhig.
Gestern Abend war ich auf einer Jubiläumsfeier in meiner Firma und habe ziemlich viel Alkohol getrunken, Doktor.
Etwa 30 Minuten vor dem Anfall hatte ich Lichtblitze vor den Augen, starke Kopfschmerzen und Herzrasen, ja.
Nach dem Anfall fühle ich mich sehr müde, mir war übel und ich war innerlich weiterhin sehr unruhig, ja.
Okay. Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Herr Hoffmann, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Jetzt sind Sie im Krankenhaus und bei uns in guten Händen.
Wir werden alles für Sie tun, okay? Frau Hoffmann.
Jetzt habe ich viele Angst, ja.
Ja, okay. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen, okay?
Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie während des Anfalls unwirkliche Wasser gelassen oder Stüllabgang?
Ja, Doktor, richtig. Ich habe mir nicht auf die Zunge gewissen und habe auch weder Wind noch Stüll verloren.
Keine Wasser gelassen, keine Stüllabgang?
Ja, ja. Außerdem habe ich keine Kopfverlassung, damit man mich festgehalten hat, als ich gefallen bin, ja.
Okay, das freut mich. Das ist eine sehr wichtige Information für uns, Frau Hoffmann. Danke für diese Information.
Gerne.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Schmerzen am Körper, in irgendwelchen Körperregionen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, ja. Mein Mann, ich habe gesagt, mein Mann hat mich festgehalten, ja.
Okay, super.
Frau Hoffmann, ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ja, nein. Jetzt nicht.
Okay. Also gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für diesen Anfall, außer Party und viel Alkoholgetröme?
Ich mange, haben Sie Schlafmangel oder hatten Sie eine Verletzung vor dem Anfall?
Ja, ich habe gelegentlich Schlafstörungen, ich habe Schlafstörungen, ja Doktor, aber sehr lange Zeit.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe viel Stress. Ich war in den letzten drei bis vier Tagen sehr nervös und innerlich unruhig, ja.
Außerdem trinke ich gestern Abend viel Alkohol, ja.
Okay, ich habe verstanden. Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich habe einzuschlafen, Doktor, ja.
Okay, und seit langem?
Seit langem, aber in den letzten zwei oder drei Tagen habe ich ungefähr zwei oder drei Stunden geschlafen, ja.
Okay, okay. Haben Sie Fieberstaff, Frohs oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, ich habe nicht beim Ecke, Doktor.
Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, ja, normalerweise habe ich keine Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang, ja.
Okay, das freut mich. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut, keine Probleme, ja.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklig Ab- oder Zugenommen?
Ja, ich habe nicht beim Ecke, Doktor.
Okay, Frau Hoffmann, leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Nein.
Okay, sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kindererkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor.
Okay, Frau Hoffmann, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich leide seit langem an Reisdarm-Syndrom, ja.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich benutze ein Medikament, ich nehme ein Medikament ein, aber jetzt erinnere ich mich nicht, Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie eine Medikamenteliste dabei?
Ich habe jetzt nicht, aber es gibt eine Liste in meiner Wohnung, ja.
Okay, Frau Hoffmann, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Frau Stipp.
Okay, ich werde Ihre Hausärztin kontaktieren, ja?
Ja, danke schön.
Okay, sonst noch etwas? Haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe chronische Knie Schmerzen und retrorikuläre Dermatitis seit langem, ja.
Und mit 18 hatte ich einmal eine Alkoholintoxikation, ja.
Okay.
Und vor zehn Jahren hatte ich einen Riss in der Hüftpfanne.
Als Baby hatte ich mit einem Jahr einen Fieberkrampf.
Außerdem habe ich Schittenbandknöchchen, die so Heiserkeit führen, ja.
Seit wann?
Seit drei Jahren.
Okay, und nehmen Sie dagegen eine Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme eine Medikament ein, aber jetzt erinnere ich mich nicht, Doktor.
Vielleicht eine Lutschtabletten oder?
Ja, ich fühle mich jetzt nicht gut, Doktor. Ich habe alle vergessen.
Okay, kein Problem. Also, wie gesagt, ich werde Ihre Hausärztin kontaktieren.
Frag mal, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen, okay?
Danke, es wäre besser, wenn Sie meine Hausärztin kontaktieren können, Doktor.
Ja, gerne. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ich wurde noch nie operiert.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf irgendwelche anderen Medikamente, außer genannten, ein?
Ja, ich nehme Ibuprofen bei Bedarf, 50 mg täglich.
Bei Bedarf, 100 mg, okay.
Okay, Frau Hoffmann, Sie haben ...
Ich erinnere mich jetzt, ja. Ich nehme 90 plus 90 Tabletten gegen die Heiserkeit, ja Doktor.
Neu angen Tabletten, ja?
Ja, ja.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie unter Klieschmerzen leiden. Welche Seite?
Linke Seite.
Und seit wann?
Seit 5 Jahren.
Okay, und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein? Ibuprofen oder?
Ja, ja, ja. Bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 500 mg, ja.
Okay, und benutzen Sie ein Medikament gegen Hautausschlag, ich meine, wetscheralikulare Probleme?
Ja, ich benutze ein Medikament, die Probleme wahrscheinlich, aber ich bin nicht sicher, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Hoffmann, sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich reagiere allergisch gegen Aya, ja Doktor.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das äußert sich mit Bauchschmerzen und Juckreis.
Okay, und rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, Doktor.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein.
Okay, das freut mich. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke zwei oder drei Mal pro Woche ein oder zwei Gläser Wein, ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich konsumiere keine Drogen, Doktor.
Super. Frau Hoffmann, leiten Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall, Bluthochdruck?
Meine Familie, oder?
Ja, Ihre Eltern.
Ja, ich verstehe, Doktor. Mein Vater hatte Theratitis von Hautentzündung, an der Schule.
Welche Seite?
Rechts. Und sie haben eine Korne-Transplantation, Operation, bei meinem Vater durchgeführt.
Ja, Ihre Mutter?
Vor vier Monaten.
Vor vier Monaten, okay.
Ja, meine Mutter hatte eine Handgeländefraktur und bei ihr wurde eine Operation durchgeführt.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand? Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie...
Ja, ja, ich bin vererratet, ja, ja, Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, habe ich eine Kind, ja.
Ist Ihr Kind gesund?
Ja, meine Kind habe einen Herzfehler, ja.
Okay. Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja, ich wohne mit meiner Familie.
Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Selbstständiger. Wir haben einen Kopi-Shop. Wir arbeiten hier mit meinem Mann, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Hofmann, das waren meine Fragen. Also, nein, Entschuldigung, besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen als regelmäßig?
Ja, Doktor, ich gehe mindestens drei Monate zu meinen Haushaltszinen.
Okay, wann waren Ihre letzte Periode?
Letzte Periode, vor zwei Wochen.
Okay. Ja, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe viele Angst. Was habe ich?
Ja, also Frau Hofmann, das ist zu früh etwas genau zu sagen, aber ich vermute, dass Sie an einem epileptischen Anfall leiden.
Aber zuerst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich mit Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen, okay?
Bleibe ich im Krankenhaus, Doktor?
Ja, ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Und wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Okay?
Okay, Doktor, ich warte auf Sie, Doktor. Danke schön.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie einen Platz im Wartezimmer, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön. Ich habe die Erfindungen von der Anfalle etwas entdeckt, aber ich habe eine Zigarre.
Schönen guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Frau Kerstin Hoffmann ist 38 Jahre alt, 1,78 Meter groß und 60 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Hoffmann stellte sich heute bei uns vor drei Stunden aufgetretener Krampfanfall vor.
Ihr Mann hat sie zu uns gebracht.
Der Patienten zufolge seien die Beschwerden heute Morgen aufgetreten.
Solche Beschwerden habe sie früher noch nie gehabt.
Sie berichtete, dass sie gestern Abend zu viel Alkohol auf einer Party getrunken und laut dem Mann der Patientin war sie eine Minute lang.
Sie war eine Minute lang erstarrt vor dem Anfall und der Anfall habe eine Minute lang gedauert.
Sie berichtete über Nervosität und Unruhigkeit seit drei bis vier Tagen vor dem Anfall.
Außerdem klagte sie über Photophobie vor 30 Minuten vor dem Anfall.
Die Fragen nach Sturmgegebissen, Sturinkontinenz, Kopfverletzung und Schmerzen am Körper wurden verneint.
Sie erwähnte, dass sie vor dem Anfall Kopfschmerzen, Tachikalie, Somnolenz und Fatigue leider nicht hatten.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis insomni in Form von einem Schlafsturmgern unaufällig.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Sie besuche ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig alle drei Monate.
Sie haben eine Diagnostik mit 18 Jahren Alkoholintoxikation und vor zehn Jahren Acetyl-Bolus-Riss.
Sie hat mit einem Jahr Diagnostik Fieberkrampf und seit drei Jahren bestehende Stimmbandknötchen.
Sie nimmt Neuangennut-Tabletten gegen Heiserkeit.
Sie nimmt Ibuprofen 500 mg bei Bedarf ein und sie benutzt Diprolen Salbe gegen Dermatitis.
Sie nimmt ein Medikament gegen Colon irritable, aber der Name von Medikamenten sollte geklärt werden.
Sie sei bisher noch nie operiert worden.
Sie habe Allergie gegen Eier, die sich durch Abdominalschmerzen und Pyrrhythes äußert.
Nikotinkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Sie trinke zwei bis dreimal zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass die Mutter wegen einer Handgelenkfraktur operiert worden sei.
Der Vater leide an keratitis rechts und bei ihm sei eine Korniertransplantation vor vier Monaten durchgeführt worden.
Sie sei Einzelkind und verheiratet.
Sie habe ein Kind, das an Vitium leidet und sie wohnt mit ihrer Familie zusammen.
Die Patienten haben eigene Kopyshop und haben viel Stress beim Alltag.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Epideptischer Anfall aus, da die Patienten typische Symptome dafür aufweisen,
dass sie unter einem Anfall leiden, Fotopsie, Nervosität, Unruhigkeit als Aura.
Sie leidet unter Fatigue, Somnolenz, Cephalgie und Tachikade nach dem Anfall.
Diese Symptome sprechen für einen epileptischen Anfall.
Die Patienten können als Differentialdiagnosen kommen Gehirntumor, Apoplex, Tier in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei den Patienten zunächst die Vitalparameter überwachen
und eine körperliche Untersuchung und eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Störungen der Motorik, Sensorik und andere Veränderungen voll liegen.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose sich zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild CAP BSG, gegebenenfalls Lumbarpunktion, Status, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine CT des Schädels durchführen, um die möglichen organischen Pathologien, wie Gehirnblutungen, Gehirntumor, auszuschließen.
Danach würde ich eine EEG durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Wie gesagt würde ich eine Lumbarpunktion durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien, wie zum Beispiel Meningitis oder Supra-arachnoidal Blutung auszuschließen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Danach würde ich einen Venösezugang legen und gegebenenfalls würde ich Benzodiazepin, Walbrück Acid verabreichen.
Und ich würde ein neurologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Nach der Akutbehandlung würde ich den Patienten in die Abteilung des neurologischen Klinik einweisen.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, ich denke in diesem Fall auch Gehirntumor, Apoptex und ja. Wie können wir diese Diagnose ausschließen?
Ja, wir sollen eine CT-Dest
Schäden oder gegebenenfalls MRT-Dest Schäden durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien, wie zum Beispiel Blutungen oder Gehirntumor auszuschließen.
Wie können wir Apoplex ausschließen?
Ja, die Fission gewichtete MRT können wir durchführen, um eine Apoplex oder Tier ausschließen.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde eine EEG durchführen. Können Sie uns EEG aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über EEG aufklären.
Elektroencephalographie ist eine Untersuchung, mit der wir die elektrische Aktivität des Gehirns aufzeichnen können.
Dazu werden mehrere Elektroden auf dem Kopf befestigt und diese Elektroden messen die elektrische Aktivität des Gehirns und zeigen sie als Kurve auf einem Monitor.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Epilepsie oder andere Schlafstörungen oder andere Gehirnkrankheiten zu erkennen.
Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung. Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontaindikationen. Der Patient soll ruhig auf dem Rücken liegen.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
In welcher Situation würden Sie eine Lomberfunktion durchführen?
Wenn der Patient unter Fieber leidet und wenn die Untersuchungen wie z.B. Kernigzeichen, Brudzinski-Zeichen positiv sind, können wir eine Lomberfunktion durchführen.
Oder wenn wir eine Gehirnblutung, z.B. Subarachnoidla-Blutungen, denken, können wir auch eine Lomberfunktion durchführen.
Wie können wir eine Lomberfunktion durchführen?
Zuerst müssen wir die Funktionsstelle desinfizieren. Wir machen diese Untersuchung auf dem Sitzungsposition.
Der Patient soll ein bisschen vorne beugen.
Danach führen wir eine dünne Nadel zwischen der vierten und fünften Lumbarwirbelsäule ein.
Danach entnehmen wir Nervenwasser in eine Typ. Danach legen wir einen Verband auf die Funktionsstelle.
Nach der Untersuchung soll der Patient eine halbe Stunde im Krankenhaus bleiben zur Beobachtung.
Wenn es kein Problem wie z.B. Nachblutungen gibt, kann der Patient nach Hause gehen.
Welche Schadenkrankheiten verursacht ein epilepsisches Anfall?
Metabolische Probleme wie z.B. starke Elektrolyte-Veränderungen können einen epileptischen Anfall verursachen.
Gehirntumor, cerebrale Blutungen, ein epileptisches Anfall.
Vielleicht andere Dämielinsen, Krankheiten, Traumata, Hypoglykämie.
Hat dieser Patient Fieber?
Der Patient hat keine Fieber.
Wie können wir Gehirntumor ausschließen?
Wir sollen zuerst eine CT-Deschädung durchführen um mögliche Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Gegebenenfalls sollen wir auch eine M.H.T. des Schädels durchführen um die Katsinom zu beurteilen.
Und wir können auch eine P.C.T. durchführen um die Gehirntumor und auch die Metastase genau zu beurteilen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall mit Kontrastmittel CT-Deschädels oder M.H.T. des Schädels durchführen oder ohne Kontrastmittel?
Ich würde mit Kontrastmittel eine CT und M.H.T. durchführen.
Was beobachten wir während der Akutbehandlung?
Zuerst müssen wir die Vitaparameter überwachen und müssen die Atemwege öffnen und erhalten.
Danach können wir den Patienten Benzodiazepin verabreichen um den epileptischen Anfall zu kontrollieren.
Welche Schnelltests führen Sie durch?
Schnelltest? Meinen Sie Blutgasanalyse?
Und Omozuka?
Ja, Omozuka.
Und gibt es Schnelltestmöglichkeiten?
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde den Patienten stationärer Akut nehmen.
Was erwarten Sie während der Stationäre aufnehmen?
Wir können die Patienten kontrollieren, überwachen ob sie einen neuen epileptischen Anfall haben.
Deswegen können wir eine kontinuierliche EEG anschließen um die möglichen neuen Anfälle zu kontrollieren.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen. Bitte gehen Sie zu unserem Info-Desk und nehmen Sie Ihre Certificate.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihr Arbeitsweg.